hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll and a few
months ago I went on Twitter and took a
brave contrarians stance that empathy is
a good thing many people of course would
agree with this automatically but many
other people have read a book by today's
guest Yale psychology professor Paul
bloom which is entitled against empathy
which I admit is a completely awesome
book title and Paul and I actually
discussed this on Twitter he's an
extremely reasonable thoughtful guy and
we do in fact disagree his point is that
empathy the ability to think about
things from someone else's point of view
to put yourself in their shoes sounds
good and maybe it makes us nice people
on a personal level but it gets in the
way of being rational moral thinkers we
tend to empathize with people close by
with people like our cells rather than
being purely rational about how to be
the best people how to live in the world
correctly I on the other hand tend to
emphasize the fact that people who think
that they're being rational will often
take things into account that make
perfect sense from their point of view
while perhaps not paying as much
attention to things that are front and
center to people who are living very
different lives than them to me if
you're really going to be rational it is
absolutely crucial that you were
empathetic that you try to understand
what other people who have very
different experiences than you have been
going through so Paul and I talked about
this on the podcast I don't think we are
necessarily coming to any agreement but
on the other hand I don't think we
disagreed that much either we're trying
to emphasize different aspects of a
problem and Paul's an extremely
interesting guy I think you'll get a lot
out of this conversation and hopefully
we'll all be more moral and good to each
other at the end of it
so as always please check out the
mindscape web page at preposterous
universe comm slash podcast where you'll
find links to patreon and PayPal and
keep the podcast going also you'll find
transcripts so you get to see all the
words and you can even search through
all the archives to see what cool stuff
previous mindscape guests have said and
with that let's go
[Music]
Paul bloom welcome to the mindscape
podcast thanks for having me here I want
to actually thank you especially because
a few months ago I was having dinner
with our mutual friend Carl Zimmer
it was a previous mind Kaye mindscape
guest and Carl mentioned that every time
he runs into you you say like boy I was
just long another podcast there's just
so many these things that's I presume
that you're quite in demand in this
medium well yeah but but there's a
couple that stand out and yours is one
of them oh that's good to hear good yeah
I know of you through Carl and through
your popular books and and so I'm just
I'm just totally it's riddled set to be
here and and you and I have had a run in
on Twitter if I remember if you want to
call that a run in yeah I mean I've had
run-ins that didn't seem like a runnin
from my perspective it was a nice little
chat a nice little chat but that sort of
sets the stage for us to talk in person
yeah that's right so there's lots of
things to talk about obviously in
psychology it's a pretty broad area and
you've done you've worked on working a
lot of areas let me float a hypothesis
and you can either shoot it down or or
sharpen it up a lot of your work seems
to deal with what we might think of as
the boundary between reason and emotion
or almost the battle lines between those
two things is that a fair
characterization it really is I mean
particularly my recent work I've I've
always been interested in in how much of
our natures are based on emotion
feelings and gut reactions and to what
extent could rational liberation play a
role so so this cross cuts across a lot
of my research yeah so what's the answer
how rational can human beings be I think
this is actually a more involved topic
than just a simple yes-or-no answer yeah
but I'll go for it I think we're a lot
more rational than most of my colleagues
think we are I I don't doubt that a lot
of our our feelings our judgments really
our moral judgments are influenced by
our emotions we're often very irrational
indeed certainly politically I think
politics brings out to worse than us but
I also think we have a tremendous
capacity for rational liberation and in
fact you see this at its best in in this
sort of your day job
in science in actual sciences shows that
humans can under optimal circumstances
be rational deliberative and come to
real insights about the world and I
would make the stronger claim that we
could do this when it comes to morality
when it comes to politics and in our
everyday lives good so this is a perfect
starting point for the conversation
because as I have grown older and
whether or not wiser my faith in human
rationality has only diminished over
time so I'm very happy if you are going
to be able to convince me otherwise
why don't we start just you know is the
it's a broad audience from a lot of
backgrounds I most people probably think
of themselves as pretty rational what
are the reasons that we've had from
psychology and elsewhere to start to
doubt that were personal perfectly
rational beings it's a good it's a good
way to begin there's a lot of sort of
striking demonstrations from psychology
that we aren't as smart as we think we
are and I think the foundations of this
work come from the psychologist Danny
Kahneman and Amos Tversky right and and
Kahneman eventually won the Nobel Prize
for his work in economics and what those
two did was put together a really
impressive body of work showing that
were highly susceptible to two cognitive
illusions and cognitive biases we are we
we are biased we we make mistakes we
depart from logical norms mathematical
norms in such ways that we could often
be tricked an extent and we could people
could exploit us right and so there's a
lot of those demonstrator tend to be
sort of more mathematical logic II
demonstrations but but some of them are
quite striking for instance one one
typical one is we we radically
overestimate the odds of the likelihood
of infrequent yet very salient events
like terrorist attacks are being bitten
by a shark
right and infinitely underestimate the
relative likelihood of pretty frequent
events like you know heart heart
conditions and dying of a coronary so
that's one tradition and in a second
addition is more recent and associated
people like Jonathan Haight who argue
when it comes to our moral reasoning and
political reasoning we might think that
we are we have arguments
you might think your views on abortion
and death penalty and Donald Trump are
because you're deliberating being but
there's a lot of demonstrations
suggesting that actually your views and
these things were determined by other
factors and the reasons you give her
after the fact justifications so that's
why a lot of my colleagues are skeptical
about the power of reason yeah I think
that that fits in with the very first
episode we had a mindscape where I
talked to Carol Tamra's is a social
psychologist who has done some work on
cognitive dissonance and you know she
wrote a wonderful book with Eliot
arenson called mistakes were made but
not by me all about how we justify the
decisions we make and even if the making
of the decision was rational the
justification of it would go forward
whether or not that original decision
was rational yes that's right that's
right and Rizzo Lisa
these sort of laboratory demonstrations
everyday demonstrations suggesting that
in some way we aren't we don't live our
life as sort of comic-book scientists
you know to running experiments in the
world and coming up with theories rather
we're kind of like to use Jonathan Hyde
Stern more like lawyers you know we have
a weed we have to explain something we
have to make a case for something after
it happened that's right we have to
justify it and in fact in the you know
science-fiction realm we caricature mr.
Spock and Commander data and the
examples of people without emotions
perfectly rational or there are always
the ones learning from we human beings
because we're wise and we have our gut
instincts and our emotions are very
helpful yeah I mean science fiction I
think a even good science fiction really
bungles emotions so so you know and I
know I so part of you capture one part
of it which is somehow data and Spock
are fatally flawed in some way which
they needed to touch the spark of
emotion that only a Captain Kirk has
yeah that humans have on the other hand
I think that that they terribly miss out
on importance of emotions as motivators
if spunk and data really had no emotions
why would they get out of that why would
they do things why would they what what
would you know why wouldn't they just
sit in a lump in a fetal position and
think thoughts well as David Hume said
reason is the slave of the passions
right we need some emotion
to give us goals and then reason should
tell us how to achieve those goals
roughly speaking right that's right and
even you know people like me who want to
push the importance of reason would
argue that um that you need to kick in
the pants of emotion right I i I've
argued that we're often much better when
it comes to morality when we try to
think our way through and not follow our
gut but even I would admit that if we
didn't have gut motivations to care
about other people you could come to all
the wise moral decisions you want you
wouldn't do anything
well good but I think that so that is a
important fact about the role of
rationality is that when we invoke it
it's in the cause of some goal which
arguably is given to us by emotions but
what you're saying about rationality is
something a little bit different I guess
which is you're saying that despite
these social science studies saying all
the different ways in which human beings
justify ourselves and make logical
mistakes you're optimistic about the
extent to which we're reasonable that's
right and I'm optimistic for all sorts
of reasons one reason is we have certain
domains where rationality has you know
proven to be very powerful and very
useful science and technology being one
example right if we really were such
stupid creatures and so so reflective
and so biased how did we come over time
to have such a rich understanding of the
universe of domains that we were not
evolutionarily prepared to know about
yet somehow we managed to figure it out
I think more controversially morality is
another domain where a lot better people
then we were a thousand years ago and
part of it is I think to exercise a
reason over time yeah so good let's dig
into this a little bit because I like
doing the science first I think that
science is the perfect example that
psychologists and philosophers should
take care of because if we can't figure
out how science works then then it's
hopeless like science is the most
straightforward thing that we have it's
much easier than morality and you as you
say the power of Reason has taken us
pretty far in science and understanding
the world but then you know a lot of
people on the streets are not very good
at science right we human beings need to
vent all sorts of tricks and
double-blind studies to prevent
ourselves from giving in to our biases
so is there any way of quantifying
whether or not we're overall rational or
irrational
yeah um in some way I push back a little
bit science is in some way a very
strange domain I mean for the reasons
you gave it's very unnatural way it's
this bizarre thing maybe we stumble on
to and as turned out to be of
extraordinary use and I think science
illustrate something which I think what
brings together your your observation
with the man on the street with my
pushing a reasoning which is that reason
will flourish in social institutions
where it's valued and often we're
sensitive enough to of our own
weaknesses that we can intelligently
create institutions and mechanisms and
procedures like refutation and
experiment and blind review and so on
that can lead us to do much better and I
think we see this in other domains at
all as well so you know if I'm aware of
my racial biases I could choose to use a
procedure like blind review or a quota
system or something to override them if
I'm aware that I love my kids more than
I love other people and would favor them
I could support a system which bans
nepotistic hiring and so this is sort of
a very human story we're where we have
these weaknesses but we're also smart
enough to think our way through and
override them and science is this great
example of how people manage to do that
yeah no I think I mean part of it maybe
is not that there's any disagreement or
even difference going on here but just a
choice to emphasize one thing or another
right like in some sense we are burdened
with some level of irrationality but we
are blessed with enough rationality we
can overcome that when it's really
helpful that's right and then where you
draw the line and emphasis you put on
things you know matters a lot so a lot
of my colleagues emphasize their
rationality
of our political behavior our voting
behavior my temptation is to be more
skeptical but these claims of
irrationality and argue for instance
that a lot of people's political
behavior seems irrational because
psychologists miss out on the fact that
people aren't actually aspiring towards
the truth you know if I really support
the Red Sox and I share them on and you
just say well that's not rational
they're not favored - we're missing the
point Mike my cheering them on is not
you know this objective assessment or
being right matters my cheering them on
might have to do with the community I'm
with and who my friends are and who I
want to support and that seems to be
very compatible with what I've read
about political allegiances right that a
lot of times even we're asked factual
questions we give answers because in our
minds subconsciously or consciously
those are the right answers to give
given our political side that's right so
so you take somebody who has a view left
or right to say about climate change and
you say oh well isn't it crazy this
person doesn't know what they're talking
about and they just have the view that
other people have but your average
person doesn't have much stake in being
right about climate change or or anyone
or other political issues they have very
little say in what happens whether I
have the right view or wrong you will
have no influence on my life or anyone
else's life but it will matter a lot for
my friendships in my relationships yeah
if I hold a certain view and so people
see I think people think of politics
maybe not unreasonably as akin to sports
and so they cheer on their team they boo
to other team you know for a while I'll
take one example years ago there was a
lot of polling that found a lot of
Republicans said they believed that
Obama was um was born in Kenya right
trendsetters Ashley polling where
they've asked people where it was Trump
born and a lot of Democrats say Trump
was born outside the United States we're
saying is they're saying I haven't
studied these issues I'm saying blue
Obama young Trump right and there's even
studies where if you like offer them a
nickel for getting the right answer
suddenly their answers change right
exactly when you
to incentive structure and make it that
it's Raschi for once important to be
right then people start behaving
differently and I actually think when it
comes to local politics people are much
smarter they might vote their
self-interest but they're actually
genuinely curious and engaged in the
facts because they matter whether or not
you put a stop sign on a corner are you
put in sidewalks so you pay more for
snow removal well that's the sort of
thing where where it actually does
matter to my life and my views do matter
and then I become more aligned to the
truth but let me see if I I've read I
think most of condiments book Thinking
Fast and Slow which is one of those
wonderful books that once you read it it
you know changes the way you think about
the world and the impression I get from
it is that not being a trained
psychologist you know I think a lot of
us have a vision of a human being or at
least ourselves as like it or not a
little homunculus inside our brain right
you know pushing around the levels the
levers to make us do things and that's
not a very good picture because what's
inside the monk Ulysses brain but it's
right the more psychologically accurate
picture is that there's lots of
competing sub processes going on and
there's lots of heuristics and shortcuts
and and you know commonsensical rules of
thumb that we use rather than using the
full force of our reason to get a right
answer and then give it in a single
unified consciousness I mean that's very
much right though though conovan himself
has long defended a view that says that
there are two general systems and each
system probably composed is composed of
many systems so one system is what
you're talking about now it's a series
of gut instincts and emotional responses
heuristic and bias heuristics and biases
but the second system is a deliberate
err it is a slow careful reasoner right
and and much of life we used a quick
emotional system you know in fractions
of a second we make judgments we let our
biases go but we can slow it down
you know when given a puzzle a bat and a
ball cost together a dollar ten the bat
cost ten cents more than the ball how
much does the ball cost right have you
done that one no but I could do it I
know I've read the book right so I know
how to I like slow down and get it right
I realize under this pressure everybody
mangle the example but there's all sorts
of things like that where there's an
immediate answer and then there's a slow
and reflective answer that's right
and and you know to get back to what you
were saying before people do differ
there are people who are very reflective
in their lives and people who tend to go
more for their gut but I think that
which one you are depends in part in
your nature but also depends an
environment you're in and and your
upbringing and so on but um but but this
illustrates that that in addition to the
sort of hodgepodge of heuristics and
biases that you're talking about there's
also something else in our heads that's
closer to an ideal reasoner at least in
principle well right so in this picture
you know Kahneman I think if I'm getting
the the numbers right it's a system one
which is all the heuristics and biases
and system two which is the deliberate
err the cognitive part are you are you
what is what you're trying to say that
we're more system two than we give
ourselves credit for or that system two
is more powerful when we choose to use
it um both okay well and and I think
system two is a really important part of
the story
psychologists like to say look people
people make all sorts of dumb mistakes
and we talk all about these dumb
mistakes yeah but what's I call it well
you know so one example I saw is that um
I think was Burger King opened up at in
response to the quarter pounder they had
a third pounder yes I see and and then
the idea was nobody bought it because
they figured a third pounder must have
less meat in the quarter pounder because
three is less than four so you know we
love that stuff so we think you know but
but here's what we're missing we're
missing the fact that I could tell it to
you and we could laugh about it because
there's another part of ourselves that
knows that's a mistake right and so
we're put in a kind of odd position of
almost laughing at people in ourselves
for our stupid mistakes and forgetting
about the fact that we know there's
but mistakes yeah and and and and this
is not it's not a minor problem I think
um I think our psychologists focus on
the irrational has left us largely
unprepared to explain things like moral
and scientific and social progress right
which often work on deliberation and
even if system to the rationalize err
only works one percent of the time it's
a very important one percent sure and is
this is this you know pushback that you
want to give you know the pro power of
reason kind of thing is that based on
studies or experiments that you're doing
or you just sort of you know surveying
the existing art there so in my own work
I've been most interested in this into
the domain of morality and and and big
the the basis for my critique my
critique of my my basically my
descriptive claim is were capable of
moral reasoning much more than many of
us think and in my normative claim I
claim at how we should live our lives as
we really do better as we were better
people morally better when we rely on
our reasoning rather than our gut
feelings yeah and so I try and my other
work I've sort of argued against that
emotions like disgust lead us morally
astray more recently I've argued is
about empathy our unit empathy colitas
often leads us to make bad and immoral
choices and that the basis for my
argument is to some extent philosophical
argue arguments and examples from
philosophers showing the limitations of
empathy and to some extent experimental
there's some very clever experiments by
a Dan Batson and many others showing how
illustrating a very sharp terms how
relying on our feelings leads to
terrible and immoral mistakes right yeah
so that's a you wrote a book against
empathy one of the great titles the
history of books was about my title it's
it's a it catches people's eye but has
had no end of trouble you know I took me
a while to learn the lesson of being an
author that the title is the purpose of
the titles not to summarize the book
it's to sell the book to people to read
it I think that it worked for your book
Mitel seems to be to provoke people to
send me unhinged emails well I'm sorry
to hear that yeah that's too bad but if
they do that after buying the book then
their job here is done
unbalanced they don't regret it good so
I do think so this is where we started
to disagree on Twitter and I think we
still disagree but again I'm gonna be
open up here to you changing my mind
once and for all
tell me how this be systemic how you
define empathy and why you think that we
give it too much credit yeah I mean one
of the worse things about this topic is
I'm forced to start in the most boring
of all ways by defining my terms
people use their empathy in all sorts of
ways and a lot of people think empathy
just means goodness and kindness and
morality right and if you know if
they're using term that way I'm not
against it and and I I'm all in favor of
being good and kind and moral III
meaning in a reasonably narrow sense but
it's how a lot of psychologists and
philosophers use it which is getting in
another person's shoes of feeling what
they feel seeing the world through their
eyes feeling their pain and this seems
like a very good thing and there's all
sorts of examples where it could be a
good thing but the problem is when used
when you you come to your moral views
and your moral decisions based on
zooming in on on through the perspective
another person several things happen for
one thing it's very biased I'm much more
likely to feel empathy for you a fellow
professor maybe same age same ethnicity
then I am to feel empathy for somebody
who is a different color skin or a woman
or lives in a far-off land speaks a
different language so there's that kind
of bias I'm more likely to feel empathy
for their attractive than ugly for the
safe than scary empathy is in numeron
and so empathy draws us to the fate of
the one but leaves us neutral or
ignoring the fate of the hundred and
just to kind of wrap it up because
empathy is sort of so-so bias and can be
focused it's often used as a tool for
for what I think is our our unpleasant
ends last night our president gave a
speech to the nation where he argued for
a border wall now putting aside
not that you know it's not a topic for
here whether arguing it's a good one or
that one but putting that aside what
you'll notice is Donald Trump uses
empathic arguments all the time she
talks about victims he talks all the
time for victims and people who are
murdered and people who are raped and
this is a tried and true method to
generate animosity towards a group so
when some people think of empathy they
think of charity I tend to think of war
yeah empathy is just use you can be
weaponized and often is and certainly is
in these times yeah that actually
harkens back to podcast I did with Yasha
Monk where he talks about the word
populism and you might think that
populism is would be a good thing we
have a democracy you should do what the
people want but in practice populism is
all about defining some people as not
the people right as outside the set of
people who really matter I think that's
right I think there are all sorts of
things that that feel good but if you
look at how they're used in everyday
life they are they have terrible ends
yeah and I again I this might end up
being one of those things where in fact
we're in complete agreement but are just
choosing to emphasize different things
but let's get play that out and get on
the table so I think I understand your
argument and in in some sense much of
what you say is just obviously true
right I mean clearly we are more
empathetic for people who are like
ourselves and therefore that causes
trouble is it safe to say that what you
would like to emphasize instead of
empathy is a more strictly rational
approach to morality yeah III I think
that there are always gonna be I'm not
pretending that I have a solution to
moral problems you know I don't know
whether I'm utilitarian or deontological
ders there's a whole lot of problems I'm
not pretending to solve but when we rid
ourselves of making decisions based on
on empathic pull it leads to changes in
our moral judgments that I think
everybody would agree are are better I
think
there's nobody who would defend the idea
that an attractive person's life is
worth more than an ugly person
or that one life is worth more than 100
so yeah my claim would be that the
alternative to empathy in that regard is
thinking through realizing what your
moral goals are and trying to figure out
what's the best way to achieve them okay
good so two concerns or two thoughts in
my mind first is I can't help but think
that the problem that you're raising is
not that we have empathy but that we
don't always do it right or almost that
we don't have enough empathy for the
right people right like if if it's true
that I have a lot of empathy for a small
child drowning in the pond that I'm
walking by and I don't have empathy for
starving millions of people in Africa
then wouldn't an alternative different
strategy just be well trained yourself
to have more empathy for the people who
are in Africa yeah I think that's very
reasonable there are two issues with it
one is I think there's some problems
with empathy which really are intrinsic
to empathy so empathy by its very nature
zooms you in on single individuals so
empathy is not a mental system that
deals with numbers and to the extent
that some moral judgments should deal
with numbers that a thousand lives or
two more than ten empathy leaves you
silent in fact it's kind of worse
because empathy prioritizes a single
individual you zoom in on and at the
expense of faceless individuals who you
don't now you could imagine you know if
God tried to make decisions through
empathy and God could empathize with a
billion creatures at the same time maybe
it'd be less of a problem yeah but we're
we're we're limited and an empathy is
for us a spotlight and spotlight
spotlight shine brightly on indeed on
spaces but but they have their limits
and then just the second point is it's
true if we could apply empathy in an
unbiased fashion it would be many the
problems I'm talking about wouldn't
arise mm-hmm well we can't it's it's
sort of it's sort of like I said look
you have to decide on on a graduate
student or or a new faculty member to
hire just choose the one you like the
most
but try to make it so your liking isn't
biased well if you're liking wasn't
biased if you're liking was fully on the
merits and liking is a good measure but
but that's not how people work you're
gonna like somebody who who kind of is
charming and acts and is interested in
you and it comes from a similar place so
a better system is trying to make it so
that you don't use liking use more
objective criteria right I mean in some
sense yeah we started with this
discussion of the relationship between
reason and emotions and how emotion sort
of provide a starting point for a reason
to then say okay here's our here's our
program let's carry it out couldn't
there be a similar situation with
empathy where empathy gives us a
starting point then reason takes over
and says well wait a minute it's a
little bit unfair just to be empathetic
with this person let's take the thing
that we started with and be more
rational about it it could I mean
empathy could be a spark for good
actions you could see somebody suffering
feel their pain and then move to help
them and you're helping them could be
mindful of other people it could be it
could be respectful it could have none
of the problems I worry about I don't
doubt that that could happen on the
other hand you could feel empathy for a
group of people and it could lead you
towards violence towards another group
of people yeah I think so I think that
the point that you make that empathy
tends to be singular that it's easier to
have this response with you know a
person with a face and a description and
so forth that's a very good point and
that's a very very few sensible moral
systems that say that's that should be
our motivation that's right that's right
so I sometimes you know people say well
are you pushing you know a Peter Singer
like consequentialism ours are certain
moral position then I have my biases but
to see that empathy leads you astray I
think you could make the case that no
matter where what your morality is
within a certain reasonable range you
say hey that's not the right way to do
it
right but you know to go back to your
point I you're entirely right and I
would happily concede that empathy could
spark you towards good moral actions so
- for anger anger is a very interesting
emotion anger sometimes gets a bad rap
and I think we could do better than be
motivated by anger
but anger at an injustice could really
motivate you to do really good stuff as
well I think in general though I try to
push this a subtitle on my book which is
less in-your-face in the title is the
key is the case for rational compassion
right and I think you know what what
people call compassion a general desire
to improve people's lives I think that's
a better motivator than then either
empathy or anger or disgust or shame or
guilt but yeah again I wouldn't I don't
disagree that I can have all sorts of
cases where empathy as well as anger
disgust shame or guilt led to good
action yeah now that's perfectly fair
you know that it doesn't I don't say it
doesn't matter but there's all sorts of
starting points for good things that we
could that we can get to that's I mean
suppose you and I probably don't like
racism very much racism is bad yeah
we're not gonna edit this one out on
racism is bad but but is a trivial
exercise to think of cases where racism
could have a good effect you know if you
um if you think for instance it is a
horrible politician and somebody uses
racist appeals to keep anybody from
electing this horrible politician and as
a result the world is so much better
well racism did some good that's still
you'd say yeah but in general it's a bad
way to do things
it's not it's not sort of attuned to
morally relevant features that you want
to focus on good this is very clarifying
I think that you know there certainly is
a lot of truth here and the connotations
of the word empathy are just so positive
I mean this is why against empathy is
such a great book title right that it
deserves a little bit of pushback just
so we can you know even if it's only to
think of it properly overall I think it
goes back to what you started with which
is I kind of want to make the case for a
reason and against emotions and other
work I tried to argue that look disgust
is a very unreliable way to make moral
decisions but what I found was everybody
agreed with me I mean liberal know you
of people who read these kinds of books
and I know is that makes total sense
yeah so I want to say well what sort of
emotion would you think would be good
and but but and I can make the case that
even for
you're better off with more rational
approaches so that that brought me to
empathy right so let me get on to the my
second point then which is actually
where we started on Twitter cuz like I
tried to make a I said I forget exactly
what I said but I think the point was
that empathy is a crucial part of
rationality in a very real sense and so
this is what I really want to get your
opinion on cuz I don't think that we
quite got there on Twitter I because I
am skeptical about human beings ability
to be rational but as a trained
scientist I know that we can get there
by using you know tricks and strategies
to make ourselves seem more rational I
think that one of the most important
tricks and strategies is the need to try
to empathize with people unlike
ourselves and what I see over and over
again in people who are it well self
described is extremely rational and to
be fair often are rational but they're
choosing to look at certain things going
on in the world and just not paying
attention to other things going on in
the world and I would argue it's because
they are very different than the people
that that's happening to so they just
discount these bad things I just just
this morning read an article in The
Paris Review by ro Kwok about you know
how difficult it is for her to read
novels by male authors describing female
characters because they just don't get
the fear that women live in walking down
the streets at night by themselves and I
think that one of the major tricks that
a person trying to be rational should
use if they want to get a theory of
morality and justice and how to arrange
society is doing everything they can do
empathize with people very unlike
themselves yeah I think there's a lot of
truth to that and and that kind of
brings us a little bit in different
senses of empathy so one sense of
empathy isn't a matter of feeling what
another one feels
I actually think among other things
we're not very good at it so for me to
say to Walter to a woman in that
position for instance who oh I could
really get to understand and feel what
it's like to be in your situation seems
arrogant
and but I do think and I think you're
right I think we should make an effort
to try to understand the lives of people
very different from us it makes us
better people
it makes us understand the world more
it's fascinating I mean that's so much
of the best literature and movies and
books is the exhilaration of trying to
understand a world different from your
own yeah I think but I would want to be
a little bit further than that you know
I think that because I as a scientist as
a physicist you know I know all of the
strategies that we use like I when I had
Kip Thorne on the podcast we talked
about this fact that the LIGO experiment
that detected gravitational waves they
had a whole protocol by which a little
subcommittee would inject fake signals
into the data and then the entire rest
of the collaboration would have to
pretend well they would they would not
know whether there was a real signal or
fake so they would analyze the data
write a paper the whole bit because that
was the only way to be fair and I think
that you know likewise when we're
talking about you know racism we all
agree racism is bad but there's lots of
people who think that racism is racism
is basically over that there aren't
really bad effects from racism and I
think that those people whether whatever
conclusions they reach they have an
obligation to really try very very hard
to make sure they are seeing things from
the perspective of people who are
suffering from racism and that seems to
me to be the definition of empathy I
would agree with that but I think it's
important to get the causality right so
it's not like I'm a guy who just doesn't
care about other races I just care about
myself and I think there's no problem
race and so on you know and and then I
mean if in case example and then I
somehow find myself empathizing with
somebody from a far-off land or or you
know a racial minority might community
that expands my moral circle I don't
think that's actually how it happens I
don't think we find ourselves almost by
accident empathizing people whose lives
are very different from ours
we're often very good at keeping our
empathy close close in closed in I think
what happens is is people come through
rationality and other means
to a broader worldview a more
cosmopolitan view say and then because
of this states use to empathize with
others and try to understand the lives
of others and you know I I I hate to be
too agreeable but but I I do think if
I'm in a you know there was one running
a diverse lab yeah with people with
different backgrounds I might have a
fundamentalist Christian I might have
someone who is as a severe hearing
disability and so on in order to run
this well with both practically and also
trying to be a good person like I should
try my best to know what it's like to be
these other people I do think though
that the best way to find out isn't to
go through some empathic exercise it's
mostly usually to ask them hmm
high-speed always very good advice I
agree you know um I I think there's
somewhat of an arrogance to say that
somebody like you or someone like me
could could feel what it's like to be in
a very different situation we try
there's a pleasure and trying that's
what literature movies and so on but if
I really want to know what it's like to
be to have you know a severe disability
or come from a very different culture or
be be a fundamentalist in a in a very
secular society I don't think empathy
itself in the senses or the gritting my
teeth and trying to put myself in a
person's shoes as a way to go I think
what you do is you talk to the person
you treat them as as and and you you you
come to conclusion at and maybe say look
I'm actually not gonna end up knowing
what it's like to be a woman in a sexist
society I'm really not I'm never gonna
really feel it but I could listen to
people in that situation talk to them of
what's fair what's decent what satisfies
principles of justice and morality and
follow that so maybe I am actually being
being disagreeable I would argue that
somebody with no capacity for empathy in
any interesting sense who was willing to
listen to people and who had who honored
principles of justice and morality and
fairness could be like a great moral
person and could do very well in the
world well someone who really wanted to
feel what it's like to be other people I
actually think is is running all sorts
of sort of moral and practical risks
good actually I'd like I love that even
though that's just sort of a you know
final emphasis I think that really
crystallizes what I take to be the heart
of what you're saying that I am very
happy to agree with that you know it's
interesting the thought experiment of
someone who had no empathy
I could I could agree that you know as
long as we somehow gave them the right
moral starting point they could you know
be a very moral person and then I would
say just to be troublesome about it that
since none of us are that person and we
do have empathy that and we do have
other emotions discussed and tribal
identification and so forth that empathy
the the combination of rationality and
empathy aimed at the right people is a
crucial tool in overcoming our first
most primitive instincts there you go
well that's not bad actually you know
the books long been out so I'm willing
to concede some points but let me put it
this way and I'm curious whether you'd
agree or disagree I think that suppose
you are just take you take the example
that we're both familiar with if you're
running a large and diverse lab of a lot
of people or Department or something
with a lot of people I actually think
high levels of empathy are more likely
to be a hindrance than a help
they will do good in exactly the way
you're talking about it will give you
the person the possibility of feeling
what it's like to be somebody who's very
different from them but as is typically
utilized the person of high empathy will
just feel a lot about the fates of
people who stand early elicit empathy it
takes a lot of effort to shift empathy
from the usual targets and focus them to
people who aren't the usual targets it's
it's like um it's like any sort of bias
there's this there's underlying bias
towards the familiar and the friendly
and the people like you that mean that
people hi empathy I mean people hi
feelings in general will just naturally
direct these feelings towards those who
are like them yeah they have the
capacity to do otherwise but but you
know ninety percent of time they'll be
zooming in on that purse
who was just like them when they were in
graduate school yeah and and how could
you not understand that person struggles
and difficulty well there's this you
know weird person in the corner of the
funny clothes and a funny accent yeah I
can imagine what it's like to be them
but there's a lot of work good you know
I think at this point we're slicing the
Bologna of our differences very family
and most people get it I mean you want
to correctly I think point out that
giving in to the empathy that we
naturally have can lead to just as many
deleterious consequences as good ones I
want to emphasize the fact that trying
to have emphysema thief or people unlike
ourselves is a useful corrective good
people can give choose their own balance
there yeah yeah but you you you're not
done you're not done writing books
you're oh you're you're moving on to
other things I've noticed that you're
interested in cruelty these days I'm
very much hoping that the sequel to
against empathy will be in favor of
cruelty that'd be a great book title
leaning in of the contrary in part yeah
I'm I'm actually quite against against
cruelty
oh no but III will satisfy your appetite
for the controversial um I have
heterodox views about dehumanization
result which is so um so maybe I'd be
maybe my book could be in favor of the
humanization or at least dehumanization
is not the problem you think it is yeah
I mean it's related to the empathy thing
right it's you know putting our selves
and the in the shoes of somebody else
and now you're sort of turning that on
its head a little bit how do we perceive
or think about the people who are not
being nice to that's right and and it so
it stems from my empathy work which is a
really sensible challenge to me is look
if you didn't have empathy you wouldn't
really relate fully see the humanity of
other people and when you don't see the
humanity of other people they argue you
dehumanize them you don't think of them
as fully human and once you do that
that's terrible that's morally terrible
so so if you really know what it's like
to be another person you really feel
what it's like to be then you treat them
as full humans
you have to treat them with respect and
love this is a conventional point of
view I think every word of its wrong I
dehumanizing is awful if to treat
somebody as less than human is to make a
moral and factual mistake but I've been
convinced by a lot of people really
smart thinkers on this like claim
Anthony Appiah and Kate men and and and
and others uh-huh
some of the worst things we do to other
people are in the full recognition of
their humanity so right so this is very
depressing conclusion I have to say it's
a very depressing conclusion the
dehumanization thesis is so cheerful
yeah it basically says you know look you
know all the evil in the world it's
based on a mystique you know if you if
people are confusingly think the Jews or
the blacks or the gays or the women
aren't fully human once they come to
their senses and realize that they're
real people then then all this cruelty
and nasty stuff will go away it's it's
so cheering but I but I think when you
look at atrocities in everyday violence
and cruelty often it's motivated by a
full appreciation of others humanity so
um so there's also the case studies Kate
man makes the case we regarding
regarding gendered violence like like
domestic abuse of women by men and she
says look what when you know when this
guy hates women or hate cesare beats up
on his spouse it's not that he's
thinking of them oh they're non-human
they're just things they're just objects
if you thought that why would you want
to make people suffer why would you be
so angry at them rather he's responding
in a way one responds to people people
people could be a source of delight and
love and transcendence but people could
really make you mad if I if I wanna if
Sean if I wanted to make you suffer well
the way that would happen is if somehow
I thought you you were humiliating me
are you you had done some horrible moral
wrong or you were too steep threat to me
all very human things well if I thought
of you as just an object or a machine
well then maybe I wouldn't treat you
kindly but I'd have no interest in
hurting you
yeah we don't go out of our way to abuse
chairs and tables right way to abuse
people
exactly exactly now now again
dehumanization is terrible because we
also don't go out of our way to treat
chairs and tables with any respect or
any kindness so so a lot of mass
exterminations off and say well they're
just vermin yeah but but torture
degradation humiliation both that sort
of drazi level but also at individual
level seem to involve the supposition
that you're dealing with people and you
know ders Eve there's some laboratory
work on on this finding that sometimes
when you view somebody as morally wrong
at morally bad individual you in fact
you you exaggerate their human traits as
if to to make it sort of more their
evilness more salient and to give you
more of an invitation to hurt them can
you give me an example of that yeah this
is um this is work bye bye bye tage ray
and his colleagues very nice research
where um where you give people scenarios
where you you ask them to do different
things to people it's all hypothetical
pen and paper stuff so in one condition
you say um what if I gave you a large
sum of money to break this guy's thumb
right and in other conditions I imagine
that imagine so much money you can't
help but do it
and then another condition is this guy
is a serial rapist give great detail now
suppose you decide on this grounds to
break his thumb if you're willing to do
it it shifts your feelings towards him
in different ways so if you're if you if
you're hurting him is instrumental
you'll tend to dehumanize him it doesn't
matter is not much of a person anyway
hmm but if you're hurting of him is sort
of moralistic and and and and Ray does
studies moralistic violence you tend to
accelerate his human traits similarly if
you want to get somebody to hurt
somebody for money you'll do better by
saying oh they're just a thing they
don't feel much yeah but if you want to
get somebody to her
somebody else in response to something
that that person did if you focus on
their moral traits you'll do better so
you know and again this has political
resonance think think how you would act
if you want people to lash out at
immigrants what you would say about
immigrants and and and it depends the
sort of if you want them to ignore the
immigrants are just treat them as as
dispensable or disposable you'd say one
thing if you wanted them to really hate
them you would say another right and so
what does this teach us about human
psychology I mean in some sense is it a
little bit too glib to say we don't want
to go around hurting people so if you
know just for instrumentally we're paid
money we want to dehumanize them but
there's this countervailing punishment
reflex or cruelty reflex punishment
moralization a lot of people pointed out
that that when when we do win recruit to
one another we don't um we don't didn't
think of ourselves as villains we don't
say oh my god I'm such a terrible person
for wanting that person to suffer rather
we're often proud of ourselves we think
of ourselves as moral agents you um you
can you see this in the political realm
you see that incredibly yeah I'm on
Twitter a lot too much but well it's an
experimental lab for cruelty you know
it's a good place as any
it's all data um and you see the
extraordinary nastiness directed towards
some groups of people against other
groups of people because they're you
know people the hatred directed towards
I know social justice warriors on the
one hand versus you know men's rights
activists on the other hand right and
the people directing this hatred and
cruelty don't think god I'm such a
terrible person for doing this rather
they're proud of themselves because
because you know Harvey Weinstein art
Donald Trump or Bernie Sanders whoever
it is target is they have it coming
they're bad people and they have it
coming and and what this suggests is in
general and in which I think is true is
is that our moral feelings towards other
people
are have multiple consequences it drives
drives compassion and love and kindness
browser drives drives cruelty and
reprisal and punishment and so seeing
somebody as a person as has all sorts of
consequences yeah is it so do we
conclude that in some sense we have
natural tendencies proclivities toward
reward and Punishment
with respect to other people we think
some people should be rewarded some
people just should be punished as the
right valorous just thing to do we do
and I think this is universal and in in
my own day job I've done worse studies
with children and babies and we have
research suggesting that by a child's
first birthday they have some moral
intuitions they distinguish good guys
from bad guys they favor good guys over
bad guys you look at about 18 month olds
18 month olds will reward good guys and
no punish bad guys by giving treats are
taking away treats a few years later you
get the emergence of so-called
altruistic punishment where they'll
actually give up resources to make
another one suffer and there's big
cultural differences in this and it
changes across an age and gender and
society but I think what you're talking
about the desire to reward the good and
punish the bad is actually part of our
human nature and it's not just you know
casual cruelty to people we meet it has
it sounds like it has important
implications for the criminal justice
system for example it does it does and
and so you know take one example um
there's a lot of people think victims
impact statements are wonderful things
where the victim talks about the trauma
he or she has had but a death of being
raped or being assaulted or death of a
child or something and then the jury it
are to judge now based on that
determines the punishment and I could
see III know why people favor this
giving the victim a voice is very
powerful but this seems to have all the
worst features of empathy desire right
since that means if a victim is an
attractive articulate person there'll be
a greater punishment towards the
perpetrator
then if the victim is a Glee in solid
right but so yeah this is very much in
along this theme of the relationship
between reason and emotion right the the
victim statement is is blatantly
appealing to emotion right it's Co it's
not saying well this person did the
following things that will plug into an
algorithm and figure out how to treat
them in the criminal justice system it's
saying no what they did is like really
emotionally resonant so they should be
treated worse and what you're saying is
that's no way to run a justice system I
am that's exactly right just like I
think empathy is no way to guide who
were we're kind to are what we do for
charity
our punitive impulses would often feed
off of empathy our terrible way to run a
criminal justice system for all sorts of
reasons of bias depending on who the
individual is but also because the
question of how much something offends
our gut is actually not a really good
way to decide how to mete out punishment
right and I think here I'm more or less
completely on board I think the
anti-cruelty is an easier sell than the
anti empathy bandwagon but just just for
purposes of conversation let me push
back a little bit you know we did start
by saying there is this relationship
between emotion and reason you know
isn't there something to be said for
letting some of our emotional residents
into our decision-making process even if
that emotional resonance is this person
is bad they should be punished they
should be treated badly yeah I I I think
it's sort of a question of where and
when I don't think much of the claim and
I don't think I don't think is what
you're arguing for that because of our
emotions about some of you did a
horrible crime prison rape becomes this
you know amusing matter to us weird idea
of somebody being raped in prison is is
a source of amusement and pleasure I
think that that's sort of allowing us to
exercise the worst aspects of ourselves
on the other hand um I'm not you know I
I think you're raising an important
point which is you know to have a rich
life is to have a life that's and
it's emotions and emotions play an
important role regulating our feelings
towards others so I'm not against being
biased towards your friends over other
people your family toward other people
I'm not against feeling empathy for
those you love and in sort of intimate
personal ways or and I'm not even
against some degree of retribution or or
punitive aspects you know toward towards
people and everyday interactions you
know if you if you read a savage review
of my book you know well you know where
we are human strain above okay well you
said that but yeah book reviews I know
what it's like just for a little while
you can exercise proportionate response
yes well can we learn anything good so
there's a realization that an element of
being cruel comes not from
dehumanization but from humanization is
there does that is that actionable
intelligence you know can we learn to be
less cruel people by appreciating the
effect I think so I think in general I'm
I didn't often be quite skeptical but
psychology tells us about how to live
our everyday lives but but I think this
is one case where simply knowing it
makes a difference and this comes up in
cases it actually has come up in issues
of international relations where where
it used to be thought for instance that
if you only knew if the Israelis only
knew what it was like to be Palestinian
right then you know peace would reign
and so on and and there's been
sophisticated psychologists have looked
at this and often find that increased
intimacy and understanding of other
people's minds and what goes on to know
often makes things worse and not better
yeah if you if you really know what it's
like to be in a head of somebody who
hates you and that's not a good thing
and it may be maybe treating them as a
little bit less of an individual and
more as a problem to be solved and
something in a negotiation partner is
actually better off I think I think it
teaches us in general to be a bit more
calm
just about idea that that getting close
to another person will make us kinder to
them well I certainly do think having
had some conversations about the nature
of morality and justice and things like
that
plenty of people are willing to just
stop being rational about these things
and say no that's just wrong that's just
right I don't need to justify it anymore
and I'm certainly on board in taking
moral behavior or just behavior as being
subject to rational analysis just like
everything else that's right and and
it's it's complicated in all sorts of
interesting ways for one thing I think
in the end me and you talking us we
talked about Hume at the beginning
there's gonna be some moral intuitions
just like there's suddenly some
scientific intuitions that are sort of
rock bottom you know if you don't if you
don't agree with me that hurting people
is wrong it's not clear we have much
more to talk about right and and but you
know if you say to me well we got a we
we got to keep we're gonna have open
borders and I say oh why do you think
that you just say it's a fundamental
moral view and you know stomp your feet
well that's not very bad yeah it doesn't
sound like something that should qualify
as a fundamental even it's the right
view whether or not it's not that
fundamental it should be derived from
something a little bit more I've had
arguments about you know charter schools
yeah we're somebody this is a
fundamental moral position really and in
some way if you think of the functional
political moral arguments sometimes when
people do that they're it's not that
they they appreciate it you could
actually argue about these things what
they're saying is it's immoral to do so
what they're saying is actually given
the kind of person I am I want to be
seen and see myself as somebody who
crossed a line here
well you noted earlier that you were not
trying to take a certain stance toward
what is the once and for all correct
moral theory right but can I just ask
you know for textual purposes are you
would you qualify yourself as a more
realistic there is ultimately right and
wrong or is it more constructed by
individual people in societies yeah I'm
deaf
more realist I think that there are
facts in a matter as to what's right and
what's wrong now I'm I don't think moral
truths are the same as physical truths I
think if there were no people there be
no morality if there was no if people
were constituted differently our
morality would be differently but given
how people are constituted I think there
are things you say our moral truths or
at least moral universals so so you know
there's a lot of philosophy here at some
of it that goes meta ethics so some of
it goes over my head but I would think
that there are you could point to
another culture of humans and say
they're doing things badly and if they
came up to you and said well we agree
we've all all of us we like slavery are
we like the oppression of women I think
one could say well you're just mistaken
if you thought harder you'd realize you
shouldn't be doing things that way yeah
it's tough to say because it's like like
you already admitted it's not the same
kind of mistake as if they thought that
the earth was the center of the universe
right like it's not a mistake you can
disprove by doing some experiment that's
right that's right so it is it is harder
you can't just say well if only you had
better telescopes or paid more attention
or thought things through you simply
know this on the other hand and here I'm
kind of borrowing an argument from Sam
Harris who I don't fully agree with on
this but a but but but his argument
strikes me as good which is because
they're human you're human you guys
share certain premises lazy unnecessary
suffering is bad and you could sort of
if you spend enough time with them and
they're rational which they would be
given enough time you could persuade
them the way you're doing things say
slavery doesn't work it doesn't it it
doesn't respect people what what you
think should be respecting it doesn't
maximize what you think should be
maximized so I'm not like coming in as a
21st century American saying you're
doing things wrong by my lights rather
what I'm doing is I'm saying to them say
Nazi Germany or whatever I'm saying uh
you're doing things wrong by your lights
if you thought about as long enough
you'd realize that that that the way
you're doing things violates your own
intuition so how should be done yeah I
mean we're not gonna solve this here and
it's a little bit off topic but just I
just need to get in my disagreement with
same about exactly this point which is I
think it's kind of it might very well be
true and in as a matter of practice I'm
very willing to believe that it is true
that I can reason with very different
people doing very different things on
the basis of common moral intuitions but
I think it's a huge mistake to that and
leap from that to say we need to be more
realist
you don't need to be more realist have
to find that common ground and reason
from there and I think that as a matter
of ontology I'm not a moral realist I
think that we can you can just accept
the reality that morals are constructed
by human beings and go from there for
the purposes here I will agree with ya
moral realism is another step exactly
that's and and and and it's in it's and
I'm tentative about making that step but
at the same time you sort of asked
whether I'm a more realistic moral
relativist moral relativism is typically
associated with the position that well
if enough people within a society are
happy with some way of doing things and
that's fine by them and you and I are
both Universalists in a sense that we
think there's a fundamental human nature
so some groups can do it right some
groups can do it wrong that's enough for
me yeah I'm we're not like I said we're
not gonna go I'm not even Universalist
I'm a constructivist but that's okay it
doesn't make any difference to how you
act in the world
it's what okay my only point right now I
do approve of other people that's right
those people boy until I have them on
the podcast and then they'll get their
say but speaking of Sam you wrote a very
provocative just to wrap things up you
were too provocative little peace with
him about robots and artificial
intelligence let's let's start torturing
the robots is that a bad thing you know
could do should we extend some of the
considerations we've had here to
non-biological intelligence --is what
does your where do you come down there
you know it was it was a hugely fun
article
Sam it grew out of a fasciae podcast
discussion I had with him and and with
focusing on West world's example of West
world which was which was showing at the
time we were talking watching it and I'm
sure you know but so many some people
don't with the story of West were
originally a movie than an HBO series is
there's a in the near future they create
this wild Western fantasy which you
could visit and it contains incredibly
realistic robots who are
indistinguishable from people and some
of the guests take advantage of this to
kill to rape to torture and so on and
the so just robots right parmi yes
that's right is they're just robots who
cares yes that's right and so so you
described it was a fun article to write
it was surprisingly uncontroversial you
never know but but so what we said is
you shouldn't do that you shouldn't you
shouldn't rape and torture and and and
kill robots like that and our argument
was twofold one uh one part of it was um
that you don't know they might be
conscious and if they were conscious and
good feel pain then you definitely
shouldn't do that for the same reason
you shouldn't do it for person and and
then the second part of it is even if
you can know for sure that they weren't
conscious it seems likely to us at least
that doing this to things that were
indistinguishable from people would
affect your relationships with people so
it's like Kant's position about being
cruel to animals which is he thought
animals there's nothing wrong with being
cruel to animals but said if you if you
were it would make you cruel to people
right I mean these are two very
different arguments that you're
representing so it is not very
controversial yeah what although you
made me think that I really missed a
chance when I interviewed David Chalmers
on the podcast because we talked about
two topics which I considered to be more
or less separate one was the nature of
consciousness and the other is can be
live in a simulation and he thinks that
consciousness is not reducible to the
physical that there's a mental
properties over and above physical
properties but he also believes that the
things that happen in a simulation are
just as real
as things that happen in the so-called
real world but I didn't quite prod him
on whether or not there was tension
there you know if I simulate an
intelligence but it without the
consciousness awareness properties that
we human beings have again is it still
torture to to do bad things to it and I
think you're gonna be pretty down to
earth and say Shore it's just as just as
bad yeah III would say I would say to
there's often a fact of the matter I
mean if if I I don't know if I put a
happy face on my laptop and scream at it
and try to verbally humiliate it I'm
just doing something foolish I'm not
doing something wrong but it's same if I
yell am i Alexa over my Siri who as many
people do but so there's a fact of the
matter as to whether Sony's
consciousness aren't conscious or not
and then the second part of our argument
is that even if it isn't if it's
perfectly I'm sorry my my Alexa just
spoke up there we go
the the even if it's not conscious it
would still be bad and this is kind of a
funny argument for me to make because I
think that the claims that violent video
games make people worse and violent it
to humans is actually are actually
mistaken there's so little evidence for
it and so much evidence against it on
the other hand if you could go and beat
a child to death with your hands knowing
it's not a child but a machine yes in
distinguishment child what would that do
to you and I think the answer is nothing
good well and I think that it's
Westworld is a wonderful example to use
but I think that it's very realistic
that in the very short term this kind of
problem is going to show up right mean
we have sex dolls that are looking very
realistic we have things like Siri and
Alexa that can talk to us and you know
express emotions even if they're not
conscious by anyone's definition the
idea that it seems to us just like we
are torturing or harming
something that is is like a person is
gonna be come frightening leap possible
it is gonna it is gonna happen sooner or
later the trend is gonna go towards
increasingly complex and realistic
machines including sex robots and you
know what seems like kind of a fun goofy
science-fiction example now could be
quite serious in a decade now I mean
what would you put an estimate on how
far we are from a machine that's
indistinguishable from a person I think
that this it's a great question it
depends a lot on how careful you are
about distinguishing I think that we're
not that far from machines that you
could be tricked into thinking you're
human if you didn't try that hard right
I think if I think we're there I think
that you know there's been these
artificial intelligence programs that
can you know do call center kind of
things and and ordinary humans don't
tell the difference but if you really
put your mind to it and trying to give
them the Turing test and they would
still I think we're still very far from
being able to pass that I think so too I
think I think it's much harder than
people say and I think just maybe
possibly as with self-driving cars it's
the last 5% that's gonna kill us yeah
that's right
good so let's be nice to the robots
let's be nice to each other and let's
empathize with some people in the right
circumstances and mostly be driven by
our rationality how about that I think
that's a fine way to end all right
problem thanks so much for being on the
podcast this is very helpful and a lot
of fun thanks for having me this was
great
[Music]
you
[Music]